Quel incident ! Non, t'occupe par
contre. Voilà, toi qui cherchais des
gens rétro, il y en a là-bas. Je sais
pas, le vendeur a l'air un peu louche
quand même. Écoutez, je suis un vendeur
parfaitement normal. Regardez mon étage,
j'ai plein de choix et comme vous êtes
mon premier client, je vous le donne.
Bon, OK. Pourquoi vous rigolez ? Non,
rien. Je je pensais à des enfants morts.
Ça me fait rire. Bon ben ok, écoutez, je
prends ce jeu. Mais qu'est-ce
que quoi ? Non, excusez-moi, j'ai pas
entendu. J'étais en train de rager mon
stand.
Il y a vraiment des mecs louches qui
traînent
[Musique]
ici. 1 2 3
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
4 le semaine, on va parler de quelque
chose de complètement différent et vous
savez
Ça ça sert à rien, je suis désolé mais
vraiment euh Ouais, mais c'est la classe
quand même. Bon, bref, cette semaine
donc on va parler de quelque chose de
complètement différent. Vous savez quand
je parle de rétro par défaut en général
je parle des consoles mais le rétro
c'était pas que les consoles. Il y en a
peut-être parmi vous qui ont eu ce genre
de truc ou ce genre de chos aussi. Bah
oui, en fait c'est difficile à imaginer
pour les plus jeunes mais déjà par
exemple les jeux à l'époque ça pouvait
ressembler à ça voire même aussi il ne
ressemblait à rien du tout he puisqueil
y avait aussi moyen de récupérer des
jeux à coder entièrement toi-même. Et
donc alors ben tu devais te taper des
pages et des pages de code en basique et
si tu faisais une seule erreur en
rentrant le code ben à la fin il y avait
des erreurs partout et tu étais genre
comme
ça. Et oui parce qu'il y avait aucun
moyen de corriger une erreur qui était
loin en arrière. En fait, il fallait
tout effacer jusqu'au moment où tu avais
fait l'erreur. Non mais regardez-moi ce
manuel un peu. Franchement, c'est
difficile à imaginer qu'on pouvait
bouffer des heures et des heures en
étant gamin à taper ce genre de truc et
qu'en plus on trouvait ça amusant. Ah
ben c'est sûr que les temps ont changé.
Et là, j'ai utilisé Magikarp pour faire
un bonus de dégâts sur son Raillou. Ça a
l'air super amusant. Et et là, j'ai
utilisé une commande en sous-programme
pour rétablir la valeur zéro du line
input. Tu as été adopté. Vous savez des
fois je me demande à quoi ressemblent
maintenant les enfants qui jouaient à ça
avant. Bonjour, je m'appelle Rand, je
suis programmeur en JavaScript Ajax
DHTML en PHP+ 3. Regardez ce que vous
avez fait à notre jeunesse Amstrade de
monstre. Mais bon, c'est vrai que les
années 80 c'était quand même un autre
univers. Il y avait même des émissions
de programmation pour les enfants à la
télé. que c'est le programme et mais
est-ce que tu sais que la programmation
c'estd le travail qu'on fait sur un
ordinateur c'est à la portée de tout le
monde et que c'est aussi à la portter de
petits enfants comme toi de 8 ans, de 10
ans, des fois même plus jeunes ? Tu le
sais ça ? Non non ? Ah la programmation
c'est merveilleux. Et sinon, est-ce que
tu aimes les films de gladiateur ? Alors
bon, heureusement, il y avait les
cassettes qui te permettaient de de
jouer rapidement. Et quand je dis
rapidement, en fait, ça veut dire ça.
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Arrête de faire ça, tu vas la péter.
Enfin, rapidement dans dans 8 10 minutes
quoi, hein. Parce que oui, quand vous
vous plaigniez des temps de chargement,
regardez ce que c'était un vrai temps de
chargement à l'époque. Enfin bref,
aujourd'hui, je vais vous parler d'une
des boues les plus atomiques de
l'Amstrade, Airwolf.
[Musique]
Technique d'énervement sur clavier par
joueur du grenier. Numéro 1. Si vous n'y
arrivez pas, essayez de taper des
commandes insultantes. On sait jamais,
ça peut
marcher. Numéro 2, maintenz une touche
enfoncée pour provoquer un bruit.
Trident, ce qui vous donnera l'illusion
de faire souffrir votre ordinateur.
Numéro 3, Vals sur clavier en 6
bémol. Mais si vous voulez éviter ça,
lisez juste le de manuel.
Bon ben en attendant que ça charge, on a
le temps de parler d'autres choses. Donc
on va parler du jeunesse. Alors nous
Airwolf en France, on le connaît sous un
autre nom et là je ne dis rien. La
musique va de suite vous le
[Musique]
rappeler. Et oui, c'est évidemment Super
Coptère cette série que beaucoup de gens
de mon âge ont regardé au moins une fois
et dont tout le monde connaissait les
paroles. Super coptère, le cul par
terre, la sa mission c'est sa mère.
Ah qu'est-ce qu'on était créatif quand
on était jeune. Alors donc Airwolf sorti
en 88 aux États-Unis. Alors bon c'est un
Top Gun like he comme il en existe des
centaines sur NES. Il est pas mauvais à
proprement parler mais franchement il
c'est triste comme un frigo vide ce jeu.
Tout ce qu'il faut faire c'est régler la
direction et puis voilà c'est fini le
jeu est fini. Vous allez d'un point A à
un point B. Les ennemis viennent se
suicider tout seul dans la ligne de tir
de votre hélico. Donc bon ben ça ne pose
aucun problème. Et à moins d'être
complètement con et aussi ben peut-être
de n'avoir que deux doigts à chaque
main, vous ne pouvez pas perdre en fait
les autres phases puisque bon ben
regardez le trajet que vous devez faire
pour ramasser la dame en bas, ben c'est
ça. Et le truc qu'il faut éviter, lui il
est là donc bon ça va, c'est faisable.
Alors bon, toutes les missions sont les
mêmes, mais ne vous inquiétez pas, vous
aurez pas le temps de vous ennuyer vu
que ce jeu, il se finit en 10 minutes.
Il y a 5 missions. Chaque mission se
finit en 2 minutes montre en main, sans
déconner. Alors franchement, à 500
francs, le jeu neuf hein, vous faites un
petit calcul, le jeu vous coûte 50
francs la minute. Non mais qui t'a payé
du 50 francs la minute, autant les
dépenser pour quelque chose de plus
intéressant hein, si vous voyez ce que
je veux dire. comme par
[Musique]
exemple Louis un lit qui grce. Pourquoi
j'ai fait ça ? Alors numéro 2, je vais
vous parler de Airwolf 2 sorti sur
Amstrade. Alors pourquoi je vous parle
du 2 avant le 1 ? Ben c'est parce qu'en
fait le 2 est légèrement meilleur que le
1 et je garde le meilleur pour la fin.
Alors donc ce jeu c'est un shoot zup
extrêmement classique et franchement pas
beau d'ailleurs he pour les capacités
d'une damstrade. On dirait un jeu qui a
été fait sur ZX Spectrum. Donc on
contrôle encore une fois super coptère
qui d'après la description du jeu donc a
été envoyé dans l'espace hein. Oui
pourquoi pas ? Sauf que bon, a priori si
tu envoie un hélicoptère dans l'espace,
non seulement ça vole pas, mais en plus
le pilote meurt, hein. Bref, on se
contente d'avancer en pétant ce qu'
vient et en évitant les obstacle. Alors,
c'est pas terrible, mais par contre, le
jeu, je lui mets une mention spéciale
pour la musique qui elle est géniale,
quoi. C'est super bizarre d'avoir une
super musique dans un jeu qui est qui
lui est tout pourri,
quoi. Ah, ça te met dans l'ambiance he !
On dirait un truc super héroïque. Super
coptère hélicoptère, tu sauves la terre
et l'univers. Tu nous rends fier et fait
la guerre contre tes horribles
adversaires. Super coptère chanté par
Bernard Minet, bientôt disponible.
Par contre, c'est dommage parce qu'ils
t'ont mis les musiques de fou sur les
passages de merde. Du coup, c'est aussi
pertinent que d'avoir des musiques
épiques dans un
ascenseur. Enfin bref, Airwolf sur NES
et Airwolf 2 sur Amstrad, c'était bon.
Finalement, des jeux pas terribles, mais
c'était quand même des jeux que tu
pouvais faire en gardant ta santé
mentale parce qu'avant ça, il y a eu un
autre Airwolf. Airwolf premier du nom,
sorti en 85 pour l'Amstrade CPC 464,
aussi produit par Elite, la même boîte
qui je vous rappelle a fait Dragon Sler.
Alors pour résumer un peu ce jeu, je
dirais que si Hitler était devenu
développeur de jeux vidéos, il aurait
participé à la création de ce jeu, hein.
C'est un peu un best of de tous les
défauts de jeux qui existent en fait.
D'abord, la musique, c'est le thème de
supercopter. Vous allez l'écouter
jusqu'à l'écurement le plus total. Et
comme pour toutes les musiques qui vous
gonflent, vous allez passer par toutes
les étapes. D'abord l'étape numéro 1, ça
te fatigue. Après l'étape numéro 2, tu
détestes cette musique mais tu sais pas
pourquoi tu te mets à la chanter.
Et enfin étape numéro 3, tu la chantes
mais tu remplaces toutes les paroles par
des insultes. Super copt de merde.
de merde. Alors oui he quand même
il y a un bouton pour arrêter la musique
mais ça dure seulement une vie.
À chaque fois que tu crèves, tu dois de
nouveau appuyer sur le bouton pour
couper la musique. Mais vu que dans ce
jeu, tu meurs toutes les 5 secondes, tu
es en permanence en train d'appuyer
dessus. Je vous jure, avant cette vidéo,
j'adorais la musique de supercoptère.
Maintenant je dis juste ta gueule. Bon,
donc le Jean lui-même consiste à diriger
son hélicoptère dans une caverne à
travers les différents tableaux afin de
récupérer ses points blancs qu'on voit
là. Alors, une fois pour toutes
messieurs les concepteurs de jeu, je ne
suis pas expert militaire mais je pense
que quand un ennemi se cache dans une
caverne, on n'envoie pas les
hélicos. Déjà, le premier truc qui te
saoule quand tu commences ce jeu, c'est
le gameplay. Bon, je veux dire,
contrairement à d'autres jeux du même
genre, en fait, ici, il y a un effet de
gravité. Ce qui fait que si jamais tu
relâches ton joystick, ton hélicoptère
retombe. Donc ça veut dire que tout le
long du jeu, en permanence, tu es obligé
de compenser en donnant des petits coups
légers vers le haut afin de faire
remonter ton engin pour pas qu'ilurte le
sol. Et c'est vraiment ça qui va vous
pourrir la vie tout le long du jeu.
Tenez, prenez ces barres bleus là par
exemple. Pour passer ces barres, il faut
les péter en tirant dessus. Et
évidemment, c'est pas genre vous tapez
cinq fois dessus, disparaissent. Il faut
les détruire pixel par pixel.
Et maintenant, imaginez à quel point
c'est chiant quand il reste qu'un seul
pixel avec votre hélico qui monte et qui
descend en
permanence. C'est comme faire du tir à
l'arc sur un de
trampoline. Allez
! Oh mon dieu
! Ah ! Et en plus, sérieux, vous avez vu
que des fois ça tire vite et des fois
non ? Et ben c'est parce qu'en fait tu
ne peux tirer dans ce jeu qu'une balle à
la fois. Il faut attendre que la balle
tirée par ton hélico sorte de l'écran ou
heurte un mur afin d'en tirer une autre.
C'est pour ça que quand je rate la
cible, il faut attendre que la balle
aille tout au fond de l'écran pour tirer
la
suivante. Et évidemment, s'il te reste
un seul pixel, tu peux pas passer. Ça te
bouffe toute ta vie en un coup, hein. Ah
oui, j'avais oublié de le dire, mais il
y a bien une barre de vie, hein. C'est
c'est ça en bas. Mais sérieusement, ça
pourrait autant être un crétin qui danse
que ça serait pareil tellement que ça
sert à rien. Vous savez, sur beaucoup de
jeux, quand vous prenez des dégâts, il y
a un petit temps d'invincibilité où
votre perso clignote. Là rien là rien du
tout là. Quand quand tu touches un mur,
ta vie se fait aspirer en moins d'une
seconde. Sérieux ? dans ce jeu mais tu
es en permanence en train de te cogner
sur les murs. Regarde ton hélico, il
fait la taille de la caverne.
Franchement eh même d'un écran sur
l'autre quand même quand tout va bien,
le jeu te fait des surprises. Genre ici
par exemple, tu descends d'un écran,
tout va bien et hop en dessous à la fin
du scrolling, pam, tu es dans le mur et
tu crèves. Pareil ici, tu évites le mur,
tu vas pour monter et en fait non, on
change d'écran. Tu es mort. E il y a pas
de continuité entre les écrans.
Vraiment, les mecs qui ont fait ça, il
devaient vraiment tenir une
couche. Non mais sérieusement, vous avez
déjà réussi à programmer un jeu en
tenant une couche
? Sérieusement, je vous jure que je ha
je déteste la maniabilité de ce jeu.
Pour ramasser les points blancs qui sont
l'objectif de ce jeu, tu es obligé de te
mettre en position de face qui est la
seule position qui te permet de tirer
vers le bas. Voilà comme ça. Et là, vous
voyez actuellement la situation
habituelle de ce jeu de merde, c'est que
vous tirez un pixel à côté et du coup ça
marche pas. Évidemment, il y a pas moyen
de se déplacer latéralement et tu es
obligé de faire des grands mouvements
bien larges pour essayer de te mettre
dessus. Allez, on bouffe le mur, on tire
à côté. C'est parti mesdames et
messieurs. La fête continue et
allez comme on a pas peur, on essayer un
on essaie de se placer à gauche. Là, on
est à gauche. On tape à gauche. Toujours
pas dessus. Non, là on est à droite. À
droite maintenant on essaie de se
placer. Non, on est à gauche de nouveau.
À gauche, à droite, à droite, à gauche,
à gauche, à droite, à gauche, à droite.
C'est bon. Allez, un joueur Wolf acheté,
une corne offerte. C'est
parti. Ah, qu'est-ce qu'on s'éclate ! Et
attendez, vous trouvez que c'est un
passage difficile ? Mais ça, c'est un
passage facile. C'est très facile ça.
Regardez ce que c'est un passage
difficile dans ce jeu. Ici, votre hélico
doit passer par là. C'est pas une
blague, je suis je suis totalement
sérieux. Vous savez, souvent, j'utilise
l'expression au pixel prê dans les
vidéos à tort, mais là c'est littéral,
c'est ça le pixel prè, le vrai pixel
prê. Ici, il n'y a absolument pas de
marge. Absence totale de marge d'erreur.
Pour passer cet endroit, il faut être
collé pixel à pixel à cette espèce de
machin qui flotte. Et ensuite, il faut
comme toujours compenser en permanence
vers le haut pour ne pas heurter le sol
parce que votre hélico continue à
descendre évidemment. Et il faut aussi
pas compenser trop haut parce que sinon
la queue de votre hélico va heurter les
flammes qu'on voit là de cette fusée qui
vous tue en un coup. OK ? Alors
maintenant, regardez bien les flammes de
cette fusée, hein. Vous savez, il y a
souvent des passages comme ça dans les
jeux vidéos avec un truc qui se baisse
et qui se lève à l' intervalle régulier
comme dans Dragon Slare par exemple.
D'ailleurs, notez que dans Dragon Slare,
le machin reste levé assez longtemps
pour pouvoir passer. Il y a quand même
de la marge. Maintenant, regardez le
rythme des flammes de cette fusée.
Allez, faut pas toucher le plafond, faut
pas toucher le sol, faut pas toucher le
tonneau et faut pas toucher les flammes.
Allez, on suit le rythme de la fusée.
Tac tac tac tac tac tac
tac
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tac. Qu'est-ce que vous avez fumé ? Mais
comment ? Comment ? Mais regarde le
rythme des flammes. Enfin, mais ils me
prennent pour qui là, ? Pour
Naruto. Et et puis et puis aussi, mais
qu'est-ce qu'une de fusée fout
dans une caverne ? Allez, vas-y Queen,
souffre, espèce de truc. La seule fois
où je suis passé, c'était de la chance,
rien d'autre que de la chance. Regardez
ça. Je zoome à mort sur la vidéo pour
vous faire comprendre le délire absolu
de ce passage. Regardez la photo finish,
il y a un pixel de marge. Vous réalisez
quand même à quel point un pixel c'est
petit, hein ? Là, les pes de ton hélico
touchent le pixel du toit et le bas est
à un pixel du truc qui flotte. C'est
ridicule. En plus, c'était la première
fois que j'arrivais à passer. Résultat,
après, qu'est-ce que j'ai fait ?
je suis passé. Merde, je fais quoi ? Tu
fais quoi ?
Ah et attends hein Noël est pas fini
parce que non seulement ce passage qui
est le vrai passage est impossible mais
en plus les concepteurs de ce jeu ont
aussi mis un faux passage secret ici
pour te faire croire que peut-être c'est
par là et on sait jamais alors qu'en
fait c'est pas faisable vu que tu ne
peux pas casser le truc bleu sans
toucher le plafond. Allez c'est bon
cette fois c'est clair. Elite système je
vous ajoute sur ma liste
d'ennemis. Bon donc je récapitule. Vous
devez donc passer tous les différents
tableaux de ce niveau. Je vous en ai
montré cinq ou six mais il y en a 11 en
tout. Dans ces tableaux, vous devez
récupérer ces points blancs en tirant
dessus. Je pense que vous avez bien
compris tout à l'heure à quel point
c'est la galère pour ramasser rien que
le premier. Il me faut déjà 30 secondes
rien que pour celui-là. Et maintenant la
blague finale. Il faut finir le niveau
entier en moins de 50 secondes. Attends,
non non non. Je dis des conneries là
parce que même ça c'est foiré aussi.
Même une connerie aussi simple qu'un
foutu chronomètre, ils ont pas réussi à
le programmer sans bug. Des fois le
timer t'ajoute 10 secondes, des fois il
t'en enlève 10 et tout ça sans aucune
raison. Regardez le chronomètre. 13 12
[Musique]
Non, franchement, je suis je suis désolé
mais non là j'y arrive pas. Je peux pas.
ce jeu, il y a 11 tableaux seulement et
pourtant il y a quatre erreurs par
tableau. C'est c'est incroyable, même en
faisant exprès, tu peux pas mettre
autant de bugs dans un jeu comme ça.
D'ailleurs, je suis allé vérifier sur le
netin. Je voulais vraiment voir à quoi
ressemblait la fin de ce niveau, voire
même le niveau 2. Mais vous savez quoi ?
Ce ce jeu n'a pas de fait.
Quand vous arrivez à la dernière salle
du niveau, le jeu se free et plante.
C'est systématique. Le jeu crache dès
que vous arrivez dans la dernière salle.
C'est incroyable. C'est comme s'il y
avait une force supérieure qui
t'empêchait de finir ce jeu. C'est comme
si comme si tu n'étais pas censé finir
le jeu. Comme si le jeu n'était pas
destiné aux simples humains mortels. Je
sais pas, peut-être que que le fait de
finir Wolf provoquerait un genre de
fissure dans l'espace temp qui
provoquerait la fin de l'univers.
J'arrive.
Oh, j'y arrive, j'y arrive. Je vais
finir air Wolf. je vais finir
Airwolf. Enfin, je veux dire joueur du
grenier défié des dieux. Ce jeu n'était
pas destiné au mortel. Quiconque défie
la puissance de Zeus devra jouer à
Dragon
Sler. Mais je l'ai fait il y a 2 mois.
Tortu ninja.
Oh celui-là ça fait longtemps tuis. Ah
celui-là je l'ai fini. Bordel mais tu as
vraiment une vie de merde. Quand même il
est pas si mauvais que ça Barbie Barbie
ne me dis pas que tu as joué à Barbu. Eh
mon pauvre tu as vraiment morflé
[Musique]
un pour tous pour un lorsque l'on est
mousquetaire. Un c'est tous pour un on
est comme des frères.